[Musique]
ça va toi tais toi elle est où ta soeur
on
se balade en ce moment sur le célèbre
hollywood boulevard tiens qu'est ce que
je vois salut les filles ça va comme
vous voulez salut toi c'est quoi cette
histoire elle devrait plein
[Musique]
le truc qui a tué papa tu crois qu'il
est là
qu est ce que tu as vu
[Musique]
il est gros
c'est dans le nuage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est rapide je le voyais pas bien on a
besoin de l'image que l'image des
preuves le plan qui vaut de l'or
indiscutable et nick le plan à la autres
le plan à la oprah
elle peut viser
un peu plus haut vous voulez pas nous
dire ce qui se passe ma question il ya
un truc qui rôdent dans le coin et vous
êtes la seule personne au monde qui est
capable de filmer
ce foutu nuage n'a pas bougé d'un poil
toi t'as vu un ovni dans ce nuage en a
dix lots d'un chien
claque ça m'a bouleversé
il est énorme
il est furieux il veut attirer
l'attention
il ira jusqu'au bout
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'il te choque pas
si tu le regardes pas
[Musique]
il arrive
regarde pas
à part garde par regarde pas
[Musique]
pas
radio farda
[Musique]
dégage c'est être sauvé la vie
frère et là dehors
non
[Musique]